[Music]
our own Andy Richter has partnered with
a company that's created the new
must-have product for anyone who's
nominated for a big award check it out
and the winner is
Benny googoo cartoon caboose
this is goo Goo's fourth win and fifth
nomination
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was me a year ago jealous angry
bitter estranged from my family $200,000
in gambling debt high as a kite on deck
sees Molly bath salts pet pills black
Johnny's blue Mondays Special K cat
valium some pills I found in the glove
compartment of a rental car and I was
incapable of pretending to be happy for
others well now one of those things can
change
thanks to smile buddy smile buddy is a
full-sized realistic ish grinning
doppelganger and smile buddy's always
ready to put on a good face even when
you can't or won't watch how are you
smile buddy of this year's sidekick ease
and the sidekick he goes to serve
Benjamin Gugu the Charlie Rose show
[Music]
smile buddy isn't just for awards show
disappointments it works in virtually
any situation where you're required to
mask your true ugly feelings like being
passed over for a promotion receiving a
terrible gift from a loved one eating
weird Japanese food just to be polite
going to see a co-worker's Counting
Crows tribute band shaking a hand that's
missing fingers colonic racist uber
driver that [ __ ] oldest sitcom
elderly person telling a story about a
meal he had seeing an ugly baby and
ex-boyfriend has officially moved on
what's new with you
[Music]
yeah Brittney and I got engaged
you're definitely invited to the wedding
smile buddy from the makers of rage
sacks and the stay-put menstral cage or
yours today by throwing your wallet at
the TV screen
okay money please money money smile
buddy when you can't even pretend to
feel joy
[Applause]
you